[music]
Thank you Mark for for um the uh setting
this stage. As Mark said, we focus
heavily on multi-root solutions that are
actually designed to deploy uh uh be
deployed in the field. Um, Field AI is a
company that builds software, the brain
layer for robots that is generalizable
across different embodiment. So, a lot
of embodiment you see on this photo are
today across uh uh uh the globe deployed
working doing different things with the
customer. What you see in the middle uh
is our is our brain, a compute unit, a
sensory system attached to it that sits
on multi-tonon vehicles all the way to
humanoids, four-legged robots, different
hands with different types of fingers.
And the architecture is by design
architected and built to handle
different dynamics, different types of
modalities. And this doesn't stop just
as in in robots. The brain is applicable
across different missions as well as
different environments.
Here are some of the locations in the
world our robots are operating and have
been deployed across three continents
today from North America to Europe to to
APAC region and carrying out variety of
different missions in radically
different types of environments.
When we talk about real world, this is
what we mean by it. We usually are in
settings that we refer to it as DDD,
dirty, dull, dangerous environments um
like construction sites, energy sectors,
uh manufacturing sites where the world
is quite unpredictable and quite messy.
Um this is a regime that is quite
different from uh uh lab demos, quite
different from controlled environments.
If you look at these general purpose
brain from the two lens of
generalizability
and reliability and deployability as you
go on the x-axis to the right the
requirement for reliability goes up uh
uh uh rapidly you have on the left
digital AI conversational AI things like
chat GBT you're dealing with the the
words and languages you have high
tolerance for errors hallucination you
can go and fix a few words in your email
or in your article after it's done. That
already is a big success. If 80% of job
is done, you go to lab demos, your
tolerance goes a little bit lower. In
control environment, you need to have
even less hallucination. But at the
largest sector of the market that been
predicted to be the 70% of the TAM for
robotics and autonomy, you have almost
no tolerance for errors. And this is
where a lot of traditional architectures
like transformer-based a blackbox large
neural network start struggling because
you don't have the right
interpretability. You don't have enough
of a risk awareness and uncertainty
quantification baked into into these
models.
That's a regime at Phili we we heavily
focus on uh which again we call it DDD
environments dirty dull and and
dangerous. And this comes from the lens
and sort of the DNA of the team as well.
We come from a heavy field deployment
background. Uh part of the team comes
from deep minds and metas of the world
focused on foundation models. The other
part come from NASA of the world and
self-driving car community where we have
been deploying robots from Mars to to
underground. Um uh uh Mark mentioned
this and we are um we have been
collaborating for for a long time back
in uh 7 8 years ago. We received very
first legged robots from Boston Dynamics
before even Boston Dynamics Cell it. I
used to be at NASA at that point and we
were pushing these systems to go into
Mars analog caves because those are some
of the most likely places to find signs
of life on Mars other planets because
they're uh shielded from from cosmic
rays. going into those types of
environments require you to handle an
environment you have never seen before.
There's no GPS, there's no prior map,
there are no roads, there are no
predefined information. So that was
really fun. We started there published
some papers that were first uh uh in
deploying these solutions for to
accomplish many kilometers long missions
without human intervention. Then uh um
the team has been involved and be key
members of developing coordinated Mars
helicopter rover navigation all the way
to uh winning the urban phase of DARPA
challenge and and and DARPA racer and we
started FAI in 2023. But this is to show
that this is the lens we look at the
world. We look at it from day one from
the deployment perspective. And first
question we ask is not how does
necessarily do XYZ at the highest level
but is it going to be resilient? Is it
going to be reliably operational for 3
months in the field and that comes and
changes the architecture uh of of the
solution. Um and it changes the
architecture by bringing two end of this
spectrum together from the large AI
model side the generalizability and from
the risk aware robotic AI side the
deployability of these solutions. So if
you look at it at this sort of a a a 2D
lens uh of of generalizability and
reliability uh chat GBT and
conversational AI type solution fall
into the top left right and this is
where we uh uh see today some of the
solutions that are basically taking a
large transformer model to bring it into
robotics fall into this category. uh
incredible for set of applications but
in DDD environment the hallucination is
not tolerable prone to hallucination
heavily data inefficient you need in
this regime hundreds of trillions of
tokens of data and the creativity
becomes how do I use different sources
to close that gap but it is just a huge
gap and hundreds of trillions is the
amount of data you need in
conversational AI that is a
one-dimensional problem text with
discrete 52,000 words in the dictionary
In robotics the world is very very
different highly highdimensional it's
continuous and it's still a hypothesis
how far this would generalize so what we
do at field AI is we take that all the
best in there but we combine it with
what we have been doing for the last
[snorts] 10 15 years in terms of
deployment in terms of the uncertainty
quantification and we take that
technology and bake physics bake
uncertainty quantification into these
traditionally ally blackbox large neural
networks and that's what we call field
foundation models uh that not only
generalizable but also provide a level
of risk awareness provide a level of
safety which translates you being able
to deploy these solutions across uh
these different environments without
prior information. Um
what do these robots do in the field? We
in general carry out four different
classes of uh missions and operations.
The first class is the the the part that
we don't touch the environment. We walk
around do inspection digital twin
creation. We work with Nvidia. We work
with a lot of incredible partners on
that front to understand the world to
analyze it to give trends to the to the
customers. The second class is we carry
objects. We move material with large
vehicles all the way to small platforms,
dog robots from construction site to oil
and gas refinery to data centers. The
third class is the brain generalizes to
hands, arms, and fingers for
manipulation tasks from opening, closing
doors to pressing buttons, picking up
objects, all the way to coordination
that Mark alluded to, which is the
capability that you basically take a
heterogeneous team of assets, a truck
out there, a a humanoid inside
doing manipulation work, a dog robot
doing inspection, and these
receive one mission and dispatch
themselves autonomously to different
parts of the world. I'll show you some
quick videos of some of what we do here
across these three cognitive layers. The
architecture comes and solves the
problem in three layers. The bottom
layer is what we call physical AI that
is focused on local skills, balance
manipulation. Then we go to operational
AI where the story is how you embed this
into the customer workflow and then the
multi- aent. So I'll go over these one
by one. In the bottom layer, uh we solve
the problem of you have a system and
you're trying to understand the balance.
You're trying to understand and do local
manipulation skills. So but the world is
local around you, right? So you can
change the underlying uh uh uh terrain.
You can uh uh in a in a incel operation,
you can operate and and teach the the
platform to do manipulation tasks. very
simulation aminable and highly uh uh uh
after you do the simulation come back
and in the real world do reinforcement
learning and start learning and uh more
and more um but the focus is you are
local right the task is you can collect
data in a in a in an efficient regime
you can do perform local tasks you can
locally keep the system stable and
provide these set of skills Right. Um
then uh uh uh you go to the operational
AI layer um which embeds [snorts] these
skills into the customer workflow. But
before operational AI, maybe a few other
skills to highlight it's not just
limited to humanoids. Here you see we
take very cost affordable platforms and
make up for the weakness of the body
with a better brain. We push them to the
limits of the hardware capability and
enable them to carry out different
missions. And being able to go on
different embodiment allows you to
handle and and carry out the mission
different missions for the customers. So
this one, this robot here that you were
just seeing carries 150 pound for four
hours. Um the small one is perfect for
inspection. The arms of manipulation, of
course, perfect for manipulating objects
and having a brain that goes across
these different embodiment, different
tasks is what gives you this very
powerful horizontal layer.
Um, and and similar with across
different uh humanoids and different
embodiment. I will I will skip this this
video in the interest of time but uh
highlighting how the the the the brain
adapts to different embodiment in the in
the local skill. But then the much more
important layer is the operational AI
layer. It's one thing to keep the system
stable. It's one thing on a tabletop
manipulation perform operations. It is
totally totally another thing to put
this in the the customer workflow with
all the realities of the real world
where in the first uh uh uh 10 15
minutes there's a high chance of you see
a lot of off-nominal settings different
lighting different situation people walk
and uh uh a lot of your assumptions uh
uh might break and you get out of
distribution very quickly and very
importantly to do so without imposing
infrastructure or work for customer
without doing it uh without asking the
customer to provide maps or clean up the
space for you or provide positioning
system. So all of these uh uh solutions
you see here are with our sort of paying
customers from different parts of the
world from north of Japan in the snow
all the way to deserts in Dubai to
Germany to Europe and all of these uh to
to the US. deployments are with
different embodiment
but without ever asking the customer to
hey go map the world and tell me where
different objects or different elements
are right without providing positioning
system GPS without pro cleaning the
space and having a trajectory to say
teach and repeat and the brain carries
out different types of missions with
with the same model from perimeter
security like the one you see here to
digital twin creation to uh um providing
variety of reports for our construction
customers from progress to deviation
analysis to object cataloging all the
way to actually carrying objects all the
way to doing this across larger set of
vehicles and performing manipulation
tasks. And that horizontal layer again
gives a very powerful uh capability for
the system not just on an individual
level but at a as a as a team in a
coordinated manner. Speaking of
different platforms, this is a radically
different uh uh platform. Perhaps the
highest level of autonomy we have uh uh
uh uh we have we have developed because
all in in this application all the
customer gives us is one single
waypoint. They tell us from where you
start 10 mi north, 20 mi east, there's
this flag. Go carry deliver material to
there. That's all. There are no roads.
There are no uh uh GPS. There's no
satellite imagery. There's no prior
information about the world. We might go
to the right side of a hill, hit a dense
foresty, get entangled, and then you
have to come back, go from the other
side. And I'm highlighting this to say
the input to the model is not just your
simple image or RGB or lighter scan.
It's a much larger representation of the
world. And how do you tokenize that? How
do you compactify this? How do you pass
it to a model? These are the the
problems that now you're we are working
on in the operational AI layer to give
memory reasoning to these models rather
than just have the in the in the lower
level in physical just react to
something in the local setting. Um, in
the last operation we did, we went
almost around 40 40 miles uh uh with in
an environment that robot had never uh
seen before with with no human touch.
I I'll skip these uh uh uh but this is
to to highlight uh uh the same [snorts]
technologies how they come and perform
different applications across humanoids.
Of course, manipulation and dexter
operation is still not a fully solved
problem. This is open
While a lot of our application today
with the pit paying customer these are
still a lot of of developments across
different applications from pushing
carts carrying objects to uh scanning
packing and in logistic setting moving
material and and and so on. But then we
go to the the last cognitive layer uh
the the up the multi- aent uh which is
based on our touch points with the
customers we are seeing how critical
this is and now you have a model that
handles not just a single agent but a
coordination across heterogeneous team
of agents. So in this operation, you're
looking at an an operation where we sent
11 robots, four of them with legs, four
of them with wheels, and three of them
flying into an environment they have
never seen before. We don't we have not
also seen this environment in advance.
Every camera in the environment,
everything you see are cameras installed
by the customer. We only see the
operation after mission is done from the
recorded data. The robots go in, they
discover the world and they dispatch
themselves autonomously. They see here
are stairs. Here is a boulder. I'm going
to send and dispatch a dog robot to to
handle that. Um I see a a a vertical
[snorts] shaft. The drone will take off,
map that, carry out the operation, come
back, land on the ground robot, charge
itself and carry out the operation. And
uh uh in all this operation again there
is no prior knowledge of the world no
prior map no positioning system no GPS
no uh uh predefined plans and these all
emerges out of out of the the autonomy
solution which um now we are seeing on
the commercial side there's quite a bit
of traction uh because once you can
handle heterogeneous set of assets a
truck out there a humanoid doing welding
and dog robot doing inspection and
coordinate these not you carry out the
mission but you remove a very important
uh infrastructure layer for customer and
increase the ROI quite a bit and similar
again on the humanoid side these
technologies slowly come into the
operations on the with hands and
manipulation in this case the the
humanoid closer to the camera we lock
the body and don't let it move and ask
it to put the the the part into the into
the uh into the box but because hand
cannot reach they're understanding that
they have to coordinate to be able to to
do these types of missions. But what is
the impact on the business? What's the
philosophy of field AI for us? We back
to what I started with. We don't look at
the world. We don't see robotic as a
pure data problem. We see robotics as
data problem plus a a a problem of
physics and reliability and architecture
problem. This helps us to deploy even if
there are out of distribution elements
in the environment. The physics kick in
keep you safe and that allows you to
collect data. You might be inefficient
around the parts of the environment that
you have not experienced before but
you're safe. Because you're safe, it
allows you to collect data. Data allows
you to be tomorrow more efficient around
those objects. You learn what you did
not know yesterday. That leads to more
deployment. More deployment leads to
more data and better models and that
leads to a very large uh uh flywheel of
of of of uh data that is coming from
different embodiment, different
platforms, different environments and
and learning based on that is now we are
seeing an unprecedented evolution in our
model. So in the last 2 months we have
collected as much data as we have in the
history of the last 3 years of the
company and this is sort [music] of
exponentially compounding and the model
is getting better and better. So this is
how we look at the world as we move from
physical world to uh uh to from digital
world to the physical. We believe these
robots are going to come and expand the
capacity of people and uh specifically
we see dirty doll dangerous environments
are the ones that are in most need of
these solutions. And uh our philosophy
by baking safety and risk awareness into
these models are to build this future in
a responsible in a safe and risk aware
manner. And with that thank you. Uh we
love to talk to you all if interested
what we are doing. We'd love to chat
more with you offline. Thank you.